[Music]
on this Monday night Israeli ground
forces push deeper into
Gaza while the UN is closing four
centers in Gaza Distributing Aid as
Israel's prime minister rejects calls
for a ceas fire we have to win this war
protecting Palestinian civilians your
average Israeli cannot distinguish
between palestin terrorists and
terrorized Palestinians the Israeli
Rabbi trying to stop attacks by Jewish
settlers a mob storms a Russian airport
searching for Jewish
passengers deepening concerns about a
rise in
anti-Semitism and not so fast an
embarrassing measuring problem that
voided a world record at the PanAm
games global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
for a fourth night Israeli forces are
advancing deeper into Gaza tanks
infantry and artillery advancing into
residential areas in gaza's north and
Israel's primee Minister vow it will not
stop gaza's Health Ministry says at
least
8,300 people have now been killed this
female Soldier Israel's Defense Force
says was rescued Sunday night in Gaza
she was one of the hostages taken by
Hamas during its Rampage into Southern
Israeli towns on October 7th she is the
Army says doing well and reunited with
her family
more than 200 other hostages remain in
the hands of Hamas and Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
dismissing all calls for an end to his
military
campaign calls for a ceasefire are calls
for Israel to surrender to Hamas to
surrender to terrorism to surrender to
barbarism that will not
happen our coverage tonight begins with
Mike Armstrong and a warning some of the
images in his story may be
disturbing it is a two-pronged push
these are images released by Israeli
Defense Forces it says shot Monday from
inside Gaza the strategy according to a
spokesman is to move in by ground to
engage and identify Hamas Fighters and
then to attack from the
air integrated attacks killed dozens of
terrorists the spokesman says they had
barricaded themselves in buildings and
were attacking Israeli troops moving
towards them now the bombings have Day
by Day become increasingly intense the
IDF says over the last 24 hours it has
hit more than 600 targets all the people
here look now this is what that
sometimes looks like this is video shot
by a freelance journalist working with
global news in Gaza it's on a road
people are using to move South and was
taken just moments after an explosion
knocked him off his feet oh people are
are evacuating no safe no safe
places now in the same area another
video shot by an eyewitness appear
pierced to show a car meeting a tank
turning
around and then being shelled the date
it took place is not been independently
verified the Israeli government insists
it is minimizing civilian casualties but
admits they're happening Israel's fight
is your fight the Israeli Prime Minister
met foreign journalists for just the
second time since October 7th his
message to the International Community
was that this war will be one he said
with what he called moral Clarity it
means making a moral distinction between
the deliberate murder of the innocent
and the unintentional C casualties that
accompany every legitimate War even the
most just
War well there have been warnings from
the UN that Israel may be responding to
Hamas war crimes with its own the
desperation in Gaza is worsening Sunday
an aid Warehouse was broken into by Gaza
residents who took flour and other items
un officials said Monday they're
shutting down four Aid distribution
centers and a storage facility due to a
breakdown of civil
order now there is also a new video
released by Hamas of three hostages
Global News has decided not to air it as
it may have been made under duress but
the woman who speaks in the video is
very critical of prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu saying among other things that
he failed to protect them Netanyahu
calls the video cruel psychological
propaganda but one of the hostages
families says they're just happy to see
their loved one alive Donna Mike
Armstrong in Jerusalem thanks Mike the
violence is not restricted to Gaza at
least four Palestinians were killed in
the Israeli occupied West Bank today
that's according to the Palestinian
Health
Ministry they were killed during an
early morning Israeli raid on Janine
Israel claims it found explosive devices
during those raids the Palestinian
Health Ministry says nearly 120
Palestinians have been killed in the
West Bank since October 7th it is on the
West Bank of the Jordan River it's
bordered by Jordan the Dead Sea and
Israel Israel took control of it in 1967
and Palestinians consider it illegally
occupied land of the estimated 3.2
million people living there more than
700,000 are Jewish Israelis known as
settlers Israel allowed them to move in
though Palestinians the UN and most of
the International Community consider
their settlements illegal the
settlements have grown and settlers
continue to build barriers between them
and their Palestinian neighbors the
tensions flare up every day our Danielle
hamam Jin recently visited the West Bank
and a warning some of the details in her
story are disturbing
Danielle Dona there are now fears the
West Bank is at a boiling point and
could become another front in a wider
cont conflict even the White House a
staunch Ally of Israel has urged
Benjamin Netanyahu to quote reign in
extremist
settlers the Stillness of this landscape
can be deceiving the West Bank is not
under bombardment but it is under
Israeli occupation and Israeli
settlements though a violation of
international law have only
expanded and the violence only getting
worse shootings beatings homes torched
cars torched theft attacks by Israeli
settlers against Palestinians here in
the West Bank have increased
dramatically in the past year even more
so in the past 3
weeks on a morning drive through the
village of TBE we stumble upon a family
who's just been
attacked we would defend ourselves with
weapons if we could says Muhammad but we
don't have any
he says Israeli settlers stormed his
house sprayed tear gas on his daughter
began shooting and then left with 100
sheep worth at least $50,000
us the first responder on the scene and
who some might see as an unlikely Ally
is Rabbi arik asherman he's been working
with human rights groups for
decades
documenting injustices against
Palestinians we are all in pain we are
terribly angry I've never seen anything
like this uh all the doors are closed
right now your average Israeli cannot
distinguish between Palestinian
terrorists and terrorized
Palestinians he had blue eyes and a
beard Muhammad had never seen him before
they shoot life bullets they all armed
like the C like they C they not Army
though they come civilian they have
their arms anybody moved anybody say no
to them they tried to kill
people recently in the span of a few
hours four Palestinians were killed shot
by settlers and Israeli soldiers
according to Palestinian
authorities the next day during their
funeral procession more live rounds were
fired at Palestinians killing a father
and son this is just our land it's just
that simple This Is Our Land isai fer is
a settler spokesperson in the West Bank
City of Hebron who sees no contradiction
in his beliefs fer says he doesn't
condone the attacks on
Palestinians but that the Jewish people
can't be expected to be passive and is
your goal to drive the Palestinians on
what you call your land out only jihadis
I got a problem with jihadis I have no
problem with Arabs or Palestinians I
have no problem with it people who
respect respect my law this is a tribal
region Arabs that want to live within
our tribal lands just have to respect
our laws that's the way of the Middle
East Palestinian officials say the past
three weeks have been the bloodiest in
the West Bank in the last 15 years
critics have long complained about a
culture of impunity against extremist
settlers and human rights organizations
say criminal charges against them are
extremely rare Donna Danielle thanks
Russian police have arrested dozens of
people after a mob stormed an airport
looking for Jewish passengers it
happened in the southern Russian
Republic of dagistan which has a
majority Muslim population the mob even
made it onto the tarmac looking for
people who had just arrived from Tel
Aviv Redmond Shannon on the worrying
rise in
anti-Semitism like a scene from a
century
ago but filmed on
smartphones hundreds of people stormed
dagestan's main airport shouting
anti-semitic
slogans looking for
Jews Manny make it to the tarmac running
to a plane that arrived from Israel crew
members order passengers back into the
cabin outside the terminal others
surround a passenger checking his
passport to see where he's from Dagan's
Health Ministry says 20 people were
injured although it's unclear who they
were dagistan is a semi-autonomous
Muslim majority Republic in Russia's
North Caucasus in another part of that
region a Jewish Center under
construction was set on fire over the
weekend isn't this something that our
like grandparents um told us stories
about with hundreds of people running
around looking for the Jews to harm ran
LaVine says it's particularly difficult
to watch because so many North American
Jews have roots in the former Russ
Russian Empire where attacks against
Jews were common in the 1800s
historically Jews have lived in the
region for very very very very very long
time Caucasus expert Harold Chambers
says Pro Palestinian rallies had been
banned before Sunday's Riot there's
still frankly a lot of questions up in
the air as to what how everything was
allowed to get as bad as it was the fact
that the police didn't really intervene
is a serious issue police later made 60
arrests
Russian President Vladimir Putin said
Ukraine and the West played a role in
organizing the mob something keev denies
the Russian leader has also blamed the
West for the current conflict in Israel
and Gaza and he invited Hamas leaders to
Moscow last week that and the events in
dagistan have caused concern in Israel
that the world's largest country could
be drifting toward a new outlook on the
Middle East Redmond Shannon Global News
news
London Canada's foreign affairs minister
has called for humanitarian pauses in
Israel's war on Hamas to allow foreign
Nationals and hostages to leave and
allow food Fuel and water into the
region in a foreign policy speech today
Melanie Jolie said Global Security is
fracturing Mackenzie gray on what else
she said and the pressure on Israel's
allies a new Canadian position on the
Israeli Hamas conflict 400 Canadians are
trapped in Gaza they are living in fear
and despair and as a government we have
a duty to bring them to
safety and that is why we need human
pauses a human truce in Gaza a
humanitarian truce received overwhelming
support in a non-binding motion at the
United Nations General Assembly Friday
Canada abstained from that vote which
called for an immediate and sustained
cessation of hostilities Canada's
foreign affairs minister still believes
those hostilities were Justified on the
Israeli side Israel has a right to
defend itself against terrorist attacks
it has an obligation to do so in
accordance with international law those
laws violated by Hamas after taking over
200 hostages these kids they they want
to go home and play Xbox Aon BR from
Toronto is hoping the Canadian
government will help get his four family
members taken by Hamas out of Gaza it's
about the
result and the result is bringing them
home and every day they're not home is
you know in my mind a failure similar
pressure on the federal government from
Pro Palestinian protesters calling for a
ceasefire and for more Aid to be allowed
into Gaza ceas now a message taken
directly to Liberal MP's offices across
the country we want to ceas fire because
want to see an end to this genocide and
it end frankly to um you know innocent
civilians being targeted uh from all
sides The Divide over the conflict also
felt in the liberal caucus I don't think
Israel has any choice now but to respond
to try to deal with a terror threat at
its border um that being said we want
all civilian life protected as much as
possible but 23 of Anthony house
father's liberal colleagues have taken a
different stance writing to Justin
Trudeau directly to call for a ceasefire
I am fearful about the Safety and
Security of my uh staff Conant staff as
well as my family caucus divisions and
consistent protests in Liberal writings
pose a major political risk to the Prime
Minister Donna who already finds himself
14 points down to the conservatives in
the polls
thanks McKenzie more than two years
after the Taliban returned to power in
Afghanistan Canada says it has met its
promised Target of Afghan refugees the
government says it successfully
resettled 40,000 Afghans since August of
2021 many of them include Afghan
Nationals and their families who help
Canadian agencies on the ground it
includes vulnerable groups targeted by
the Taliban women journalists and lgbtq2
people students take to the streets to
protest tuition hikes coming up calls
for the Quebec government to cancel its
controversial
plan a tentative deal has been reached
between unifor and stellantis ending a
brief strike at the automaker more than
8,000 employees walked off the job at
midnight the union and the company
negotiated through the night reaching an
agreement in less than eight hours no
details have been released but unifor
had been pushing stellantis to agree to
the same core terms the union reached
with the other big automakers and cargo
is back on the move on the St Lawrence
Seaway management and unior reached a
tentative deal Sunday in a week-long
strike that shut down the busy shipping
cdor among the sticking points were
better wages and improved working
conditions go in Montreal hundreds of
University students took to the streets
to protest the Quebec government's plan
to double tuition for outof province
students it would start next September
and tuition would nearly double going up
to about 17 ,000 a year protesters fear
it sends a message anglophone students
aren't welcome the provincial government
says the measure will help protect the
French
language still ahead I speak with a
former Israeli Prime Minister about
whether anyone is talking about peace
after Israel's
war Israel has said it intends to
annihilate Hamas if that is possible no
one is talking about what comes next
earlier today I spoke with former
Israeli Prime Minister ahood Barack
about that he is the country's most
decorated military officer and former
Chief of Staff of the army and a special
forces Commando before entering
politics ahood Barack thank you for
speaking with us today we know the
operational objective of the Israeli
military and the government is to
destroy the military capabilities of
Hamas and end its control of Gaza do you
believe that is possible it's possible
for
sure but it cannot go without toilet
sweat and tears and blood it might take
uh many weeks probably
months I hope not a year more than 200
people are being held by Hamas and Gaza
four of them well five of them are now
out uh do you believe the rest of them
can be rescued in this ground incursion
and bombardment or is it just as likely
as possible they could be killed by it
if there was any real Readiness to make
a deal we probably will be ready to do
it immediately but once there is no real
proposal on the table and as long there
is no real proposal on table it's better
for us to penetrate deeper and deeper
into Gala STP that will create the kind
of pressure that will promote the
possibility of uh of a deal about the
hostage it also create as we learn now
an opportunity to sometime to to rescue
one of them but I am fully aware of the
fact that there is also a risk do you
think that there is a risk that the
longer this goes on and as you say it
may you believe it could be it could be
months Israel will lose support from the
rest of the world yeah for sure we know
it from our experience we're gradually
losing the support we GR losing even in
in some Minds The legitimacy but we have
to uh remind ourself and the world no
country on Earth would have allow a Das
or alqaeda like um kind of a terrorist
that are executed those crimes against
humanity to live on its bord we failed
on a grand scale providing this on seven
of October we are not going to let it
happen again before October the 7th I
know you were a harsh critic of Benjamin
Netanyahu you feared he was turning
Israel into a de facto dictatorship do
you think he is the person who should be
leading the country at this most
difficult time in its history not just
Netanyahu our Armed Forces lost the
trust of the people on 7th of October
and the Prime Minister lost the trust of
the people on Seventh of October polls
which are running right now tells that
80% of the population Israel including
majority of his his own voters sees
Netanyahu as the main responsible for
this blow that Israel suffered many
people have heavy doubts about whether
it's reasonable to let the same person
who is responsible for the blunder to
lead us out of it you know better than
anyone else that there is never really a
military solution to the violence in
Gaza that there has to be a political
solution who in Israel is looking Beyond
this military phase and is there a
partner for peace on the Palestinian
side first of all I think that even
within our world
cabinet I hope and believe that they are
discussing the issue because it should
be taken uh into account in Israel there
there is a heavy dispute about what
should be the vision people like me and
believe about half of the country
believe that the only viable vision is
the two-state solution if you ask me
about today netan and the two racist
Messianic people with him there the kind
of a party of
nuts as long as they are together in the
government they have different Vision
they want one state solution which is a
wrong even a tragedy but they're in
power now so it's clear that when it is
all over as you mentioned the long
longer term I'm confident that the time
will be found first of all to solve the
debate within ourselves and then to move
forward uh toward a a better future for
all well it's good to end on a note of
optimism ah Hood Barack thank you so
much for speaking with us thank you for
having
me next why the PanAm games had to walk
back what seemed to be a record-breaking
performance at the PanAm games in Chile
things didn't quite go right in the
women's 20 kilm race walk Peru's
Kimberly Garcia won Gold and thought she
had shattered the world record by more
than 10 minutes it turned out she hadn't
after the race officials discovered the
course had not been measured properly
and was about 3 km short it's not clear
how exactly that happened the top three
finish ERS do get to keep their medals
but all athletes miss out on ranking
points to qualify for next year's Paris
Olympics that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your Canada is ardan Ontario we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at global.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]